hey 42 here during the second world war
an old stately home in southern england
called bletchley park became the home of
the allies top secret team of elite code
breakers
their task was simple
unscramble the contents of the encoded
communications being sent all over the
world in their millions by the nazis
these codebreakers were some of the
brightest men and women in the whole of
britain
hand-picked by british intelligence for
their mathematical and linguistic
brilliance and yet even in this exalted
company
one man stood comfortably head and
shoulders above the rest
today we know him as one of the founding
fathers of the computer
as the first pioneer of artificial
intelligence and as the man who broke
the unbreakable enigma machine a feat
that according to some historians ended
the second world war years early and
saved millions of lives in the process
this is the story of alan matheson
touring
one of the greatest thinkers not just of
recent times but of all time
[Music]
but this isn't your run-of-the-mill rare
genius does cool stuff kind of tale
because touring's story contains just as
much tragedy as it does triumph
just seven years after the end of the
war he helped win
alan touring was branded a criminal by
his own government and subjected to a
barbaric medical procedure known as
chemical castration two years after that
at the age of just 41
he would be dead in what i can only
describe as
unusual circumstances
but i'm guessing ahead of myself
alan turing was born in maida vale
london in the june of 1912.
a textbook child prodigy his remarkable
intellect was apparent from a very young
age with the word genius being bandied
about as early as primary school that
genius as well as his family's distant
ties to the british aristocracy saw
allen end up in sherborne one of
britain's most prestigious schools it's
also one of the oldest having been in
continuous operation for a frankly
ridiculous
1300 years
to say that alan was keen on his studies
would be a bit of an understatement his
first day at school happened to fall
during the general strike of 1926 which
pretty much shut down public transport
across the whole of britain
your average school boy would have been
absolutely delighted by this unexpected
excuse to bunk off
but alan touring was anything but
average
rather than chill at home watching
netflix he decided to tackle the 60 mile
journey to his new school
on the back of his trusty bicycle
arriving punctually for his first day
after an overnight stop in an inn
he was 13 at the time
touring went on to study mathematics at
king's college cambridge where he
continued to wow pretty much everyone he
met he graduated with first class
honours naturally and was made a fellow
at the age of just 22.
two years later while studying for his
phd at princeton he published one of the
most influential mathematics papers in
history on computable numbers with an
application to the anchaedung's problem
the paper basically gave birth to an
entirely new field of study computer
science and though you may not be too
familiar with its title there's a good
chance you've heard of the paper's most
groundbreaking idea
the universal touring machine
a touring machine is a simple device
consisting of a scanner and an infinite
tape divided up into squares performing
actions like writing or deleting a
symbol based on a predefined set of
instructions touring never planned for
such a machine to be made it was simply
a clever thought experiment designed to
advance mathematical theory
but as it happens
it was much more than that
today we know the universal touring
machine as the first ever model for what
we would now call
a computer
[Music]
touring left princeton to return to life
in cambridge in 1939
he'd always been interested in code
breaking and being a genius he was
pretty good at it too so good in fact
that he'd even done a bit of consultancy
work at the british government code and
cipher school
the organization now known as gchq
when britain declared war on germany on
the 3rd of september 1939 there was only
one place for a man like alan
bletchley park he reported promptly for
duty the very next day after hostilities
commenced
if you've ever seen the film the
imitation game which tells the story of
touring's time at bletchley you'll
probably have an idea of him as a bit of
an arrogant bellend
but the film does him a diss surface
there's no denying touring was pretty
eccentric he famously used to wear a gas
mask whilst riding his bike to bletchley
park during the summer to keep his hay
fever at bay but according to the people
who knew him best he was also charming
funny friendly and popular if a little
shy and socially awkward
anyway during the war he'd make a whole
host of important crypt analytical
breakthroughs at bletchley park but
right from the outset his main focus was
clear defeating the nazis enigma machine
it's a little known fact that the famous
machine was actually invented a good 20
years before the war
but there's a very good reason for his
longevity
put simply enigma was the most advanced
encryption device in existence
having said that operating this
formidable machine was actually pretty
straightforward
all you had to do was type your message
out on a typewriter style keyboard
then note down the corresponding
ciphertext that would flash up on the
device's light panel after each
keystroke
decoding was equally simple type the
ciphertext out on the keyboard and the
original message would magically flash
up on the light panel there was one
small catch though this neat little
process only worked if your enigma
machine was configured with exactly the
same settings as the machine on which
the message had been encoded in the
first place and that was a problem
because the enigma machine had
approximately
159 quintillion possible settings
that's a number so big it sounds like i
made it up for effect it's also so big
that it's pretty much impossible for our
puny human brains to grasp but if you
were to stack 159 quintillion human
hairs side by side
not end to end side by side
your
creepy tower of hair
would be about 1.6 light years high
not that that little comparison actually
helped all that much because the scale
of a light here is also impossible for
our puny human brains to grasp
but you get the idea 159 quintillion is
a lot
if you didn't know the exact settings
needed to decode your enigma encrypted
message the only way to crack decipher
was to try those 159 quintillion
different options
one by one to make matters even worse
german high command changed the settings
of their enigma machines on a daily
basis
so it wasn't just a case of cracking
enigma once
to gain consistent intelligence
you had to beat it every single day over
and over again
for this reason it was widely believed
that defeating the enigma machine
wasn't merely a challenging cryptography
problem
but a literal impossibility
there was however one tiny sliver of
silver lining skirting the edges of this
giant nazi black cloud
german high command had such unshakeable
trust in the strength of enigma
that they used it for all of their most
important communications
including orders given by hitler himself
that meant that breaking enigma would
give the allies well everything
battle plans information on supplies and
the position of every ship and u-boats
in the entire nazi fleet
to put that another way if the allies
could beat the enigma machine
they'd win the war
one thing i'd like to point out is that
touring didn't break enigma all on his
lonesome
as i've already said he had a team of
brilliant individuals working with him
at bletchley park
he also had the work of polish code
breakers like marion wowevsky to build
on waretzky had actually cracked a
simpler version of enigma before the war
had even started and polish intelligence
passed a huge amount of that invaluable
knowledge onto the allies still touring
was undoubtedly the driving force behind
the work at bletchley park and without
his ideas it's highly unlikely the
significantly more complex versions of
enigma that were introduced during the
war would ever have been broken
exactly how he succeeded deserves an
entire video of its own but in a
nutshell touring and his team built a
machine called the bomb
based on an earlier polish design that
helped sift through possible enigma
settings orders of magnitude faster than
a human ever could
touring's revolutionary methods also
exploited small weaknesses both in the
enigma machines themselves like the fact
no letter could be encoded as itself
and in the protocols followed by the
german soldiers who used them like the
fact that certain words were often used
at the start of multiple messages to
greatly speed up the process ultimately
enigma was beaten and the allies had
gained a weapon of almost limitless
power
but as any comic book scholar knows with
great power comes great responsibility
and the intelligence gathered from
decrypted enigma messages was no
exception
adolf hitler was many things most of
which would get this video instantly
demonetized if i was to utter them out
loud
but one thing he wasn't was a fool
if the allies suddenly started
responding to hitler's plans even before
he executed them he would be forced to
reach one of two conclusions
eva winston churchill and co had somehow
figured out how to tell the future
or they'd broke an enigma if hitler ever
realized the truth not one single
message would ever be sent using enigma
again but the allies came up with some
pretty ingenious ways to keep the
breakthrough a secret only ever acting
on intelligence when they could engineer
a convincing enough cover story for
example if an enigma message detailing
an upcoming attack on a supply convoy
was intercepted instead of just sending
in a load of destroyers to obliterate
those enemy ships the allies would
dispatch spotter planes to fly over the
area even though they already knew where
it was
so that any enemy survivors of the
resulting battle would believe they'd
been sighted legitimately to make things
even more convincing spotter planes were
even sent to fly over areas where the
allies knew the enemy wasn't
it's hard to estimate exactly what
impact breaking of the enigma had on the
war
what several historians have tried
the most often quoted figures suggest
that touring's efforts ended the war at
least two years early
saving 14 million lives in the process
some have even gone further claiming
that without touring
the allies would not have won the war at
all
just think about that for a second
military superpowers all over the world
were waging the biggest war in history
with tanks bombers artillery shells
machine guns and something like 127
million soldiers
and yet
one geeky mathematician working in
secret in an english stately home
changed the course of the war in a
manner that no weight of bombs or guns
ever could have
as i've already mentioned despite this
truly monumental feat after the war
touring wasn't given the praise he so
richly deserved
admittedly he was awarded with an obe
but the remarkable work he carried out
at bletchley park would remain a state
secret for almost 30 years instead of
basking in the glory of being one of
britain's greatest ever war heroes
touring simply went back to work making
important breakthroughs in computing
artificial intelligence and mathematical
biology it's impossible to know what
intellectual gifts he might have offered
the world had he been given just a
little more time
but touring's personal hourglass
was already fast running out of sand
the beginning of the end came with his
arrest in 1952 for what was known at the
time as
gross indecency
today we call it being a homosexual
touring had never been particularly
discreet about his sexuality
and after a break-in at his home he
admitted to the investigating officers
that he'd been in a sexual relationship
with one of the men involved
to an open-minded citizen of the 21st
century sexual orientation is a complete
non-issue
in turing's time
it was illegal
he pleaded guilty at the ensuing trial
and the judge gave him two options
touring could spend two years in jail
or undergo a medical treatment known as
chemical castration to
cure his affliction
he opted for the latter and for the
following 12 months he was forced to
endure regular estrogen injections
designed to eliminate his sex drive
this barbaric and dehumanizing excuse
for justice rendered touring impotent
and caught his breast tissue to enlarge
along with a whole host of other
unpleasant side effects to make matters
even worse the criminal conviction meant
touring security clearance was revoked
barring him from working in british
intelligence ever again
two years after his arrest at the age of
just 41 allen matheson touring
was dead
found sprawled on the floor of his home
by the housekeeper
in the inquest that followed it was
determined that he died of cyanide
poisoning in an apparent suicide
to this day that remains the most widely
accepted version of events that
traumatized by the brutal and uncaring
treatment afforded to him by the very
government he'd given so much
he took his own life but it turns out
that conclusion is anything but certain
for one thing the timings don't really
make sense
touring suicide is almost always
mentioned in the same breath as his
conviction for gross indecency and the
barbaric chemical castration that
followed with the implication being
clear
this so-called treatment was touring's
motive for taking his own life in
reality the estrogen injections had
ended a full year before touring's death
and most of the people who knew him in
those days claim he bore the indignity
of the whole sorry affair remarkably
well
of course it's impossible to say whether
that was all just a bit of stiff upper
lipping from a man who preferred to do
his suffering in private
but there are a few curious details
about the case that put suicide in
further doubt as the cause of death
a half-eaten apple was found beside
touring's body
and it was assumed he'd laced it with
cyanide before eating it rumor has it
he'd always been fascinated by the
poisoned apple from snow white and the
seven dwarfs but the apple was never
actually tested for traces of cyanide
it's also interesting that touring
didn't leave a suicide note of any kind
and that a to-do list of tasks lined up
for the following few days was found on
his desk but if not suicide
then what
touring used his box-like spare room as
a kind of mini lap
and he'd recently ordered electroplating
equipment so he could gold plate his
spoons
i told you he was eccentric
interestingly enough the process
involved the use of potassium cyanide to
dissolve the gold
leading some people to suggest that
touring did indeed kill himself but
entirely unintentionally by breathing in
cyanide fumes as he worked
[Music]
there is of course another possibility
alan turing knew a great number of
dangerous secrets
and as the second world war had proven
that man was a weapon
or at least his mind was
during his time at bletchley park
touring wrote two papers on crypt
analysis that were considered so vital
to british national security they
weren't made public until 2012.
touring also had plenty of reasons to
feel wronged by a government he'd serve
so faithfully
and it isn't beyond the realms of
possibility that someone in a position
of power decided that was a dangerous
enough combination to eliminate it
entirely
you know just to be on the safe side
it's an interesting theory though beyond
the obvious motive there isn't any
evidence to back it up whatever the
truth one thing we know for certain is
that touring's death at the age of 41
was a tragedy
this was a man who quite literally
changed the world
he prevented untold suffering by
bringing the second world war to an end
years early and his insights gave birth
to arguably the most influential
invention of the last few centuries
the computer
it wasn't until september of 2009
that touring was given a formal apology
from the british government
and four years later he was officially
pardoned by the queen herself
in 2017 a new law commonly called the
alan turing law was introduced in which
all of the almost 50 000 men who were
charged with gross indecency were
pardoned for their crime just another
small way the remarkable alan turing
changed our world for the better
thanks for watching